rien à signaler ce matin devant les
locaux de la sainte famille au robert le
personnel est au travail il semble avoir
accepté la décision du tribunal de
fort-de-france qui a nommé hier un
administrateur judiciaire pour les
quatre sculptures que compte cette
oeuvre sociale l'administration
judiciaire devra en fait mettre de
l'ordre dans cette structure
que ce soit sur le plan social sur le
plan financier mais aussi sur le plan de
l'association en elle même de la
structure de l'association
ça doit donner un audit ça doit donner
en fait une recomposition du conseil
d'administration ça doit ordonner de
nouvelles convocations pour élire un
nouveau conseil d'administration ça doit
donner de l'efficacité surtout dans la
structure et puis ça doit donner surtout
pour les enfants du mieux être
en effet il y a quelques jours des cas
de maltraitance ont été dénoncés dans
cette oeuvre sociale cades maltraitance
envers des enfants
la sainte famille est sous la
responsabilité de la ctm et les élus de
la collectivité sont conscients de la
tâche qui les attend qu'il faudra
trouver une situation dispositifs qui
permettent à la fois de protéger les
enfants ça c'est essentiel à notre
commission
en même temps de garantir évidemment des
emplois du personnel parce qu'il est
évident que le problème qui vous a mené
par des serpents de personnes à cette
commune de gouvernance et la mauvaise
gouvernance la gouvernance est stable la
sainte famille entraîner des
dysfonctionnements qui sont
préjudiciables aux enfants il faudra
lever ces questions des
dysfonctionnements signalés par deux
conseillers de la ctm louise tel et
félix catherine ils ont adressé au
procureur de la république et alfred
marie-jeanne un courrier dans lequel il
dénonçait des défauts de soins pour les
enfants des fautes d'alimentation chez
les tout petits un harcèlement de jeunes
filles dans les douches et une psychose
de la peur au sein du personnel qui
affecterait le bien-être des enfants
l'administrateur judiciaire aura une
année pour trouver des solutions à tous
ces problèmes